[Music]
like a giant crystal this house reaches
into the sky fifty-eight windows make up
the outer wall Swiss architect Boris
eglee built his family home on the
outskirts of Zurich on the slopes of a
former vineyard welcome to the trouble
in Zurich it's Swiss German for grape as
he was designing his house
Boris drew inspiration from the
surroundings this property used to be a
vineyard there are still loads of
grapevines behind the house the windows
are attached to the supporting structure
like grapes to estab branch out of the
main middle wall just like the trunk of
a vine this table stalks there was no
space for one continuous stairwell and
the rooms are not arranged into typical
floors instead they are joined by
individual staircases and platforms to
get a building permit he had to be
created when plotting the floor plan
as the she barracks devar anglish a
typically toughest part was staying
within property lines with just 291
square meters the property is small to
begin with subtract the border limit
clearance and you're left with five
times nine meters picture designing a
house just five steps wide and nine
steps long it's impossible in the end he
managed to create roughly a hundred and
thirty square meters of living space
inside it's back to basics walls and
ceilings are made of fair faced concrete
while furniture adds splashes of color
the glass facade makes the rooms appear
larger and the concrete core provides
structure in my experience when you have
a lot of glass it's important to have a
strong back to provide a sense of
security if you have glass on both sides
it's like you're lost in the sort of
limbo here you have a backing and there
you have a fantastic view this lends the
room a feeling of peace and card
each platform offers Boris's to children
little havens for retreat
none of the living spaces is larger than
15 square meters every centimeter is put
to good use with a building concept like
this its greatest strength is also its
greatest weakness that means the way the
concrete has been poured the way it has
set and is carrying the structure can no
longer be altered you can't take
anything out anymore if you did the
whole house would collapse
boys eglise architectural office l3p won
multiple awards for this design it took
a construction period of two and a half
years to realize his dream home in this
house everything is radically and
fundamentally reduced to the bare
concrete structure that's what I like
the most all those other things you do
with a house and not necessary here you
can rid yourself of all of that really
doesn't take much there are no stones to
be thrown in this glass house with his
grapevine design boys eglee has not only
created a unique home for his family he
has also placed it on a property that
was once considered impossible